ciao ragazzi come state no bongiorno no
Qui si parla spagnolo, vale la pena casa mia, non io
house in spagnolo s&p a brand is house
passo passo passo avanti vediamo non per me
non per me giovanni per me devi
rivedere le differenze tra
per e per vieni ragazzi ma quanti
volte devo ripetere quello che c'è dentro
stop l canzoni was cat nci get a
secondo ma per e per il psuv con te
e gli accenti non parlano nemmeno giovanotto devo
ascolta il giovane giovane jota
trucco solo se sei argentino
la pronuncia corretta è il trucco
Entra e Alberto te l'ho detto tu
Mi sei mancato, ti darò un'altra possibilità
ma è l'ultima verità ok